In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadium for July 11 on which we commemorate St. Olga, Princess
of Russia, named Helen in baptism, born in the land of Pscholv, into a noble family
at whose initiative the Viringians had come to Russia, Princess Olga had been endowed by
God with rare beauty and a brilliant intelligence. One day, when she was crossing the Velika river,
she met the young prince Igor, who immediately fell in love with her.
Shortly afterwards, Igor's tutor, Prince Oleg, went to seek the princess and took her to Kiev
to give her to him in marriage, in the year 903. In the year 945,
Grand Prince Igor was assassinated by the Slavs of Volhin, and the regency of the principality of Kiev
devolved on Olga until her son Sviato Slav came of age.
Governing with wisdom and mercy, but knowing nevertheless how to show a forceful character,
the princess succeeded in centralizing power, which till then had been spread widely,
and was thus able to put an end to the deadly invasions by the Slav tribes.
She organized commerce and encouraged exchanges with Byzantium,
with the aim of sowing the seeds of civilization among her people.
In the year 957, she undertook a journey to Constantinople,
where she was welcomed with pomp by Emperor Constantine VII,
Porfido Yenitos, who placed her among the highest ladies of his court, and where it seems,
she received baptism at the hands of Patriarch Polyuktus, being given the name Helena.
On her return to Russia, she traveled through the land preaching Christ,
and founded the town of Pskov, after a vision of a threefold ray of light descending from heaven.
In the absence of her son, Sviato Slav, who was away on military campaigns,
St. Olga took over the education of his three sons, Yatovolk, Oleg, and Vladimir,
but she did not succeed in having them baptized because of the opposition of their father,
who remained a convinced pagan. In the year 969, she fell ill and tried one last time to convert
the Grand Prince, but came up against his obstinate refusal. The saint then predicted the future
conversion of Russia to Christianity, and also the sad end of her son, who was assassinated three
years later by the Pechenegs. She gave her soul into God's hands on the 11th of July
in the year 969. Her relics translated to Kiev by St. Vladimir were hidden during the frequent
pillaging of the city, and it is not known where they lie. Despite the efforts of the princess
equal to the apostles, her conversion did not have immediate repercussions among her people.
She nevertheless, though, prepared that of her grandson Vladimir, unserved as yeast
for the fermenting of the Christian life in Russia, like the dawn that heralds the radiant day.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.